okay so hawkeye episode 5 is about to
break the internet and in it there's a
lot of big reveals easter eggs hidden
details and clues for what's happening
in next week's finale i just want to get
straight into it but even though the
channel is called heavy spoilers people
still get angry if i don't spell it out
so from this point onwards we're going
to be discussing everything in the
episode so check out now if you haven't
had a chance to check it out without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our episode 5 breakdown
of hawkeye now the penultimate episodes
and disney plus shows often come with
some big surprises so that we can just
hit the ground running for the finale
next week in the last episode we learned
more about the watch and watched as
clinton k tracked into echo's apartment
here they were ambushed by elena belova
who returned in this entry realizing
that a black widow was now in the mix
clint told kate that it was best that
they break up the band and thus they
went their separate ways he was probably
also angry that florence bu was blowing
up instagram as the spoiler queen three
minutes after the show was released
that's why she's the one now that kind
of takes us to this entry which answers
some questions whilst also opening up a
whole lot more now the episode is titled
ronin which of course is the moniker
that clint was going under for a lot of
end game and he returns to it in this
entry this pulls directly from the
comics in which it was a name that he
went under two and it's also the title
that ekko took about one point
potentially hinting to how things will
go in her solo show the word ronin
actually means a samurai without master
which clint was during endgame however
beyond this it also very much reflects
elena who although working under the
direction of eleanor very much won't be
being led by her for much longer now we
pick up in 2018 and can hear voice over
clips from black widow namely the
characters talking about the antidote to
the mind control that the widows are put
under in the film here we catch elena
and another agent named sonja sneaking
into the home of a woman called anna
which could be a nod of the character of
the same name from the black widow
comics elena is here to administer the
antidote and the pair spray into her
face however it turns out that she
wasn't mind controlled and is simply a
gun for hire and the mission is somewhat
bittersweet elena is clearly wrestling
with the fact that she's apart from her
sister and sonia and a joke about her
having a sex in the city lifestyle which
is a show that's set in new york new
york is where the avengers were located
however they did move upstate away from
manhattan elena also ends up visiting
there later in the episode miranda also
had short ginger hair like black widow
and yeah i've already spent too long on
this easter egg now we learned that
elena was in fact dusted during the snap
and i really love the effect that we get
here though we've seen people going and
then coming back we've never actually
seen what it was like from their
perspective and to elena she simply
disappears and comes back to find the
room has altered around here i'm not
sure why the paint on the wall didn't
just quick cut but hey not complaining
as it's such a cool transition now when
thanos carried out the snap people
didn't really die they just stopped
existing and thus coming back would have
had this strange effect on someone where
it felt like no time had passed at all
she finds anna once more only this time
she has a husband and has adopted a
child you might remember that all the
black widows were sterilized and thus
she had to do this in order to have
children having this operation meant
that they couldn't have kids as they
would probably put them above working
for dracov and it's one of the darkest
things in the mcu now throughout these
scenes elena is wearing her white
tactical suit which we of course also
saw her donning in the black widow movie
beyond that though she's also worn her
sam fisher-s goggles which pull directly
from the comics in the source material
elena was trained in the red room much
like what we saw in the aforementioned
movie in the comics elena's face was
actually swapped with natasha's a la
face-off style and this is why when
trailers for the film first drop with
her getting operated on many theorized
that it was actually her who died
getting the soul stone not me though i
swear i swear i didn't go that far that
time now they did end up reversing the
operation but due to the closeness to
her sister she very much started to see
how she'd been used as a weapon by the
red room and she left the life of a spy
behind for some time however yelena
ended up going back to her whole life as
she was turned into an adaptoid which
basically means that she can host any
power or ability that she's attacked
with yelena went against the avengers
but she ended up finding a home with the
thunderbolts which could potentially be
getting set up in the mcu we've already
had us agent the abomination and yelena
recruited and val has pretty much become
the nick fury of phase four i actually
think that elena will end up rejecting
val's team and that she'll become a new
black widow for the avengers in the
comics once she defected several clones
of her were created because she was the
best of the best of the best sir so that
could be a potential storyline for the
character now it turns out that sonia
left and ended up taking on contract
work which somewhat sets the groundwork
for the path that elena travels on with
fal she's desperate to find natasha to
tell her that she's okay but as we know
she died in endgame sacrificing herself
for the soul stone this is why elena is
desperate for revenge on clint because
she never really got to say goodbye we
then get the previously on section and
it was such a nice touch laying the
episode out like this works really well
to put us back with clint and we go to
the title sequence to see the logo once
more throughout the series this is
alternated with having arrows shot at
the target on the a when clint and kate
were working together but here that
doesn't happen because he split them up
last week kate returns home deflated and
elena seems to be happy that her
daughter is now no longer dealing with
the quote-unquote avengers level threats
we did see eleanor making a phone call
last week and in this episode we learned
that she was the one who hired elena
although elena concludes at the end that
it was her who gave her the job i would
imagine that it happened through her han
laval i'm guessing that the ending of
black widow took place whilst all this
was going on and then val went to elena
and told her about clint which is when
she went on this job we jump back to
kate's bedroom which has now been
slightly redecorated since we last saw
it in episode one much like the scene
between kate and her father eleanor and
her daughter have a really touching
moment in which she tends to her wounds
she clearly talks her out of being a
hero though which is somewhat the
opposite to what her father said in the
first century he instilled in her that
bad things will happen and that she will
have a choice to make that will be up to
her however eleanor pretty much wants to
steer her in one direction which as we
learn is because she's involved in a lot
of things now the pair look at her bow
which becomes somewhat of an inspiration
to her later on but beyond that there's
also a hawkeye poster in her room that
has clint on it he clearly didn't want
to be a role model to people but we very
much get from just this minor thing that
he means the world to kate and is
someone that she looks up to now the
vibe changes when kate tells her mother
that they've been looking into oman's
murder and have tracked things back to
jack i think at this point the most
obvious thing is that it's actually
eleanor who is working with the
tracksuit mafia and not him and this has
a lot of ties to the comics in them
kate's mother faked her own death and
ended up working with madame mask and
you just get the vibe from eleanor that
something shady is going on she of
course had that big fight with armond
just before he died and if you cast your
mind back to episode 3 you'll remember
that it was her laptop not jax that had
all the info on it about sloane limited
now mirroring the scene in which kate
had her wounds tended to we also see the
same thing happening with ekko and kazi
whereas kate and her mother are very
open with one another ekko and kazian
because they've been brought up to be
soldiers though we haven't had this
confirmed yet it seems like the dojo
where they were trained at was actually
a place in which the mafia recruited
child soldiers into their ranks and this
was overseen by the kingpin ekko is
clearly just after the ronin no matter
what but we learn later on that we got
one fan theory right and that clint was
tipped off to a dad's location by her
boss the kingpin who we'll talk about
later on in the video this actually
pulls somewhat from the comics as in
those kingpin killed echoes further and
in his dying breath he asked him to look
after his daughter kingpin took maya
under his wing and raised her like she
was his own and she became an assassin
for him however she ended up learning
the truth and she turned on kingpin
which will likely be what her solo show
centers around now next we return to
kate's apartment to find that it's been
heavily damaged by the fire that
happened in episode 2. here she's
confronted by elena who completely
steals the scene she's just here to talk
things through and as she said she
didn't try to kill kate in many ways she
put a lifeline on her in order to save
her which of course was a similar setup
to what happened with her sister and
clint during endgame elena tells her to
eat as her father says it's good for her
and this could be a no to the opening of
black widow and later the meal at one
point she talks about how she wants to
visit the empire state building the
rockefeller center and the new and
improved statue of liberty we know that
the rockefeller center will appear in
the finale next week as it's shown
heavily in the trailers and my guess is
that this is where the final battle will
take place beyond that though the new
and improved statue of liberty is where
the final battle seems to be taking
place in no way home and it now has a
captain america shield on it i haven't
seen the movie yet but i'm going tonight
and i'm very very excited now shout out
superhero nexus for saying that elena
says she loves an american christmas
which calls back to the staged one that
her and her family used to throw in
order to have some family photos again
this scene is really cool and though
elena wants to be besties kate clearly
has her guard up because of who she is
she's definitely been studying kate and
she even talks about her saving pizza
dog from getting run over in the comics
pizza dog actually got hit by a car in
the first episode and clint had to take
him into the vets which is where he lost
his eye now across town we catch clint
looking all alone on christmas and he
goes to grills his house who in the
comics was a tenant at the apartment
block that he owned in the comics cause
he actually ended up killing grylls but
i'm hoping that new york's number one
larper makes it through the show gryll
says that he has a name for clint's dog
and in the comics he was originally
called arrow however after clint took
him under his wing he said that it was
two on the nose and changed the dog's
name to lucky now elena easily becomes
the goat in the scene the reindeer meet
eating goat and she tells kate to stay
out of her way she says it's not going
to be difficult for her to complete the
assignment and it's clear florence pugh
understood the assignment as she's my
favorite performance in the show so far
now she very much has several
conversations throughout this episode
which mirror one another firstly she's
trying to free a woman from an
oppressive man then realizes that this
is her jumping to conclusions then
learns the truth about the world from
them before trying to free a woman from
an oppressive man although she doesn't
realize in this one that it's her just
too many conclusions i think going
forward that's very much gonna be the
case she says that kate very much has
hero worship for clint and this is very
much given a nod to when we look around
her room and can see a pamphlet with
hawkeye's face on it and the words hero
worship there she makes a hell of an
exit and uses the grappling hook that
his sister also of course had now back
at the home of grylls he touches upon
the new outfits that missy maid which we
know from the trailer will be showing up
next week kate returns home to find that
jack is being arrested and he says he's
never worked a day in his life which
absolutely killed me now jack at this
point is way too likable to me to be a
bad guy and i don't care if he was a
villain and better call seoul the guy is
a saint i think eleanor has clearly used
him as a patsy and will pin it all on
him i think come the end of the series
her character will be revealed to be mad
at mask and this would make a lot of
sense as both she and kingpin worked
together in the map fraction run she
also hired the mafia and held an auction
which are things that the series has
also hinted too next we go to the battle
of new york memorial which commemorates
the avengers assembling this is on the
bridge in the lead up to grand central
station which is where the infamous
scene happened he shuts himself off from
the world by taking his hearing aid out
and talks to natasha like one does when
visiting someone's grave i love how the
sound around him is completely [ __ ] off
and it's clear clint has gone through
her death several times in his head
renna knocks out of the park in this
moment and he apologizes for what he's
about to do which is to become the ronan
once more kate then wakes up and looks
around her room at the trophies before
seeing her childhood bow kate was of
course saved by clint early on in her
childhood and this inspired her to
dedicate herself to training she leaves
several voicemails tending to elena jack
and even flicks a medal which smashes
something this calls back to the time
crossing scene from last week i think
that'll be how kazya's taken out in the
comics clint flicked a toothpick at him
but as they focused on this so much i
think that will be what they do next we
jump to the tracksuit mafia in a trusted
bro van we can hear them playing
christmas in hollis by run dmc and run
dmc were of course famous for wearing
track suits they also bring up other
iconic ones including tommy smith's from
the olympics the movie the royal
tenenbaums and lastly tony soprano clint
fires a message arrow at them and says
that he wants to meet maya where she
first met the ronin this was at fat man
order repair which is a location where
her father died at clint then calls
laura and has what could be his last
conversation with her he says that he
has to end it tonight before the big guy
gets involved and it's clear he wants to
stop things before kingpin shows up now
there's a lot of focus on laura right
now and though we don't know whether
she's the person connected to the watch
that does seem like it's the most likely
scenario in case you don't know in the
comics clint was actually married to
another hero called mockingbird
mockingbird or rather barbara morse was
a shield agent drafted in under the code
name agent 19. although we don't know
much about laura and the mcu when the
avengers first went to clint's house in
the age of ultron tony did jokingly say
that he thought she was an agent
potentially linking in with his theory
due to her constantly mocking her
enemies in fights she eventually took on
the codename mockingbird but she ended
up faking her death in order to return
to being a civilian which is info that
could end up being on the watch this
would also explain why she has the name
laura instead of barbara as she would
have to change it in order to avoid
suspicion now i know there's a lot of
theories going around saying that she
could be a skrull as well and the info
on the watch might be holding that too
in the comics she was replaced by one
and this could potentially lead into
secret invasion i'm not really sure how
much stock i'd invest in that but it's a
theory going around at the moment so i
thought it's at least worth bringing up
barbara and clint did end up getting
divorced and the matt fraction run
focused on him getting his life together
which might also be setting up some
things for their relationship down the
line now laura trusts him implicitly and
says that he has to do what he has to do
to protect their family clint returns to
where he left the ronin costume and sees
that the mafia awaiting we then have an
amazing stealth scene in which he knocks
them down one by one it's really well
directed and it feels a lot like
batman's first nighting begins as we
very much see how an avenger looks
through the eyes of their enemy clinton
masks so that mai can see his face and
this is where he tells her that he was
tipped off i did have a feeling that
this would happen as maya's dad said he
was in debt over his head and
potentially kingpin had him killed as he
was unable to repay him in the comics
kingpin framed daredevil for the hit but
i actually think this works really well
in the context of the series maya says
he's lying and she ends up almost
killing clint but he's saved by kate now
maya starts to suspect causey and asks
why he wasn't at the meeting that night
and it's clear that fisk wanted him out
the way as he knew what was going down
cause he was a number two and he
definitely acted like a number 2 doing
this now i do think he was probably in
on things and that he was spared to fill
the position in the comics cause he
worked closely with the kingpin so that
makes a lot of sense shortly after kate
tells clint about elena which of course
echoes the scene with echo in which some
truths were revealed across town we see
elena following eleanor whilst kate and
clint have food with grylls it's at this
point that kate receives a text message
in which we learn elena hired elena and
she sends through a photo of willy that
it definitely has all the people gasping
sounds sounds a bit like something that
happened to me i'm just kidding yeah
i've never done that do not cancel heavy
spoilers please this is this is all i
have left now as for the kingpin we've
had a lot of clues for the character
showing up in the series so far in
episode 3 we were of course introduced
to uncle at the dojo and the black suit
that the character was wearing was very
similar to what he had on in the first
season of daredevil there was also the
character's laugh and added that the
fact that his footsteps were much
heavier than maya's dad plus when she
was older we watched as she went to fat
man order a pair which was probably a
nod to the kingpin's nickname there were
several landmarks that also appeared in
the series including the building in
episode 1 which wilson ended up buying
in daredevil season 3. now i have been
rewatching daredevil on netflix and i
forgot how much i absolutely love the
show season 2 especially is really
strong and just in case you need a quick
catch up on wilson fisk we actually
learned a lot about him throughout the
three entries fisk was raised by his
mother and father the latter of which
lost a run for city council which led to
him getting in debt with the mob
wilson's dad bill ended up trying to
instill in him the idea that power and
violence were interlinked and he even
got him to beat up one of his bullies in
order to hammer this home bill used to
make wilson stare at a wall whilst his
more abusive aspects came out in their
home and this iconography ended up
popping up throughout the season at
several points bill ended up attacking
wilson's mother in a drunken rage and
wilson ended up killing his father both
he and his mother ended up cutting up
his dad's body and they took bits of him
in bags and dumped them in the river at
night the mobsters were blamed for his
disappearance and wilson ended up taking
his dad's cufflinks to remind him of the
event he later moved to asia and learned
several languages before he returned to
new york and starred a criminal empire
he also met an art dealer called vanessa
and the pair fell in love this is where
we sort of pick up in season one and we
watches matt murdock karen page foggy
nelson and ben urich bring his dealings
to the light this led to him getting
arrested and though he almost escaped
daredevil took him down now kingpin and
i are a lot alike as we both get called
uncle and also get head in the back of
the car beyond that though he ended up
going to rikers island in season 2 and
slowly he took over the inner workings
of the prison kingpin enlisted the
punisher amongst his ranks and told him
that one of the high-ranking inmates
killed his family which then led to
frank killing them fisk betrayed frank
and eventually he escaped prison through
a corrupt fbi agent and was moved to the
presidential hotel he worked alongside
benjamin poindexter aka bullseye and
eventually matt took him down when we
last saw him he was being escorted into
custody by the fbi who denied him
getting to see vanessa they said that
because he didn't allow his victims to
say goodbye to the people that they
loved that he wouldn't get to either and
it was such a cool way to send off the
character now we don't know if this is a
water version or if the netflix stuff
will become canon but though i just
dropped that in now just in case you
need a quick rundown i think that in the
next episode that elena and clint will
come face to face once more and that
clint will reveal the truth which will
lead to them working together eleanor is
clearly the big bad for this season and
though kingpin is behind a lot of the
things i think he'll simply be put in
place to set up the echo series she'll
likely learn that he killed her father
and my guess is that she will work with
the heroes and end up taking on the
mantle of the ronin for the future of
the mcu now as for my thoughts on this
episode i definitely think it's my
favorite out of the run so far i think
when people look back on the season in a
couple of months that a lot of the
moments they remember will be from this
entry as there is a lot of standouts in
general i think when you look at the
disney plus shows i often think that the
penultimate episodes are the best ones
as they tend to have the biggest reveals
in them i feel like the creative team
just want to wrap things up so they're
more focused on sticking the landing
whereas i think these ones contain all
the big reveals so that they can just
kind of go through the motions for next
week look at me i'm already putting a
downer on the finale however i do think
the episode will be good i'm definitely
preparing myself for an action film
finale that will probably pack some big
gut punches too also i think that having
kate and elena sort of getting this
rivalry is working really well and so is
hayley steinfeld who's knocking out of
the park at the moment weirdly i've seen
kay getting called to mary c quite a lot
because we didn't see her doing any
training beyond the title sequence but
when you think about it we've seen her
doing more training than we ever saw
clint doing also she's been beaten quite
a few times in the series and hasn't
just been showing up and getting through
things easily so yeah just kind of a
weird criticism that i'm seeing quite a
lot now after a few opening couple of
episodes i wasn't too on board with i'm
really glad that the series has found
its groove and it's consistently hitting
at a high level i know there's people
out there that have loved it from the
start others that have just jumped on it
like me others that still aren't on
board but whatever your thoughts on the
series make sure you comment below and
let me know when i speak to you again i
will have seen spider-man know at home
and just in case i didn't make it
completely clear last video i won't be
posting any spoilers on the timeline
i've already done my thumbnail for it
and though i might end up using a
different image it will be along those
lines nothing beyond just saying ending
explained and that being in the title as
well is something like post credit scene
breakdown as you know we like to stuff
things with keywords but don't
unsubscribe here i'm keeping the
spoilers off the timeline anyway that's
the video and just to let you know we're
running a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the
spider-man 4k trilogies on the 30th of
december all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now say that to you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our ending
theories for no way home which will be
linked on screen right now we gave it
one final punt before we see the movie
and i don't know if i'm right don't know
if i'm wrong but go over there and tell
me if you've already seen it if not then
thanks for checking out the video i've
been paul you've been the best and i'll
see you on the next one take care peace